so Candace Owens tweeted sorry to say
sorry to the saying uh sorry to the say
it but the descendants campaign was Dead
on Arrival and it's time to admit it
tons of mistakes needed to be more
upfront about his intention to run
doesn't come across as honest and he's
boring you can say it shouldn't matter
but it does he also needed someone more
like Kaylee mcinany rather than Petty
Christina Pasha running comms the
influencers that are still cheerleading
for him are those that recently moved to
his State and want to reap the benefits
for standing firm beside beside him
through his inevitable loss I'm not
knocking The influencer Hustle just
calling it as I see it they know he
can't win either also their weird
takeover of their Community notes gives
people a fact Checker Vibe sometimes the
notes they add don't actually debunk
anything getting very snopes-like Jenna
Alice says Candace probably consulted
president Jeb for this spot on take
Canada says when you authored this tweet
did you think it was funny clever
interesting generally interested in your
thought process on this honestly chat
GPT could have come up something better